jobs report came out today
just sit down buckle up this is going to
be a this is going to be a tough
conversation oh we're just going to
start we're going to show you the
numbers first the august unemployment
report was released
i don't know who's behind all these
numbers but we got questions we got to
have a conversation
the expectations of the august
unemployment numbers
725 000 payrolls added in august
the actual was 235 000.
this is about as bad of a miss as you
can get i mean literally the numbers
came in
the expectations were three times higher
than the actual
what we're off by 65
who's getting fired for that like
the expectations were 725 000 and it
came in at 235 000. these numbers are
hard to predict they're hard to predict
but
what y'all been doing for the last 30
days like god damn that was bad
they missed by 66 percent give or take
august total was the worst since january
so much for the economy's recovering
indeed estimates that are about 10.5
million open rolls congratulations great
job world record
never been more open roles than there
are today in the us economy great work
everyone this month saw an increase of
about 400 000 in those who said they
would they couldn't work for pandemic
related reasons 400 000 people
all of a sudden said we can't work
what
how does that happen there's 5.6 million
people now that say they can't work
because of pandemic related reasons
i'm positive there are some people who
can't work because of pandemic related
reasons
400 000 new people
there's more people who decided that
they can't work now because of pandemic
related reasons than payrolls that were
added in the month of august
almost two times more
what's going on
what is happening
how does this make any sense
someone please explain to me i'm just
a regular dude who's trying to
understand how is it that two times more
people
say
in the
18 months after the pandemic
after the recession end
sorry i can no longer participate in the
job market because of pandemic related
reasons
two times more people said that in the
month of august than people who actually
got a job
what is going on
are the numbers wrong
or is the world just mad
i have no clue
we have two charts for you
big miss
you know when bloomberg i believe this
is uses the bureau of labor statistics
which we outsourced to bloomberg great
job bloomberg we should give you some
raise uh appreciate i think it was
actually cnbc at the christmas party
it's byob though don't get carried away
don't be getting crazy
don't be coming to our christmas party
thinking you're going to get drunk for
free uh the big miss payroll has
increased by far less than forecasts i
mean
you got to give them credit whoever
whoever put this on the chart that said
big miss as the title and then they had
to explain it in the next sentence they
said payroll's increase by far less like
much more uh you know i don't know what
else we could say then forecast
unemployment rate falls so when you
start to look at this is the smallest
gain since january important to call out
two things one it is a game we did add
jobs in august that is a net positive in
the sense that we added it not good that
we did it with such a small amount two
as john alluded to these are very very
hard to predict i can't do better right
to be clear john and joe can't do better
but i can tell you that if i made a
prediction
on a number like this that was only i
don't know 30 45 days away and i was off
by 60 plus percent i probably would stop
like i probably would just stop trying
to predict the number if i'm off by that
much and so the good news is that the
unemployment rate has fallen down to 5.2
percent but we're still at five plus
percent unemployment in our country we
have 10.5 million jobs open the most
that the u.s economy has ever had open
it would not surprise me if we cross
over 11 million open rolls before the
end of the year so all that
fear-mongering about automation about
robotics about everyone's going to lose
their job baloney there's literally more
open jobs now than there ever has been
in the u.s economy but somehow someway
we only added 235 000 payrolls in august
thoughts
so what's driving this right like is it
companies not wanting to uh people not
wanting to go back to work because of
the delta variant is it government
intervention and stimulus checks is it
uh people savings rate went up this year
so they're being a little more picky
like what is driving it right like how
do we get out of this bro
400 000 people
claim
that they can't work because of pandemic
related reasons yeah but like i don't
even know what that means right they
don't
you know what i mean like i have no idea
what that means nobody knows sway nobody
knows
ain't nobody knows
yeah i just don't know what that even
means right like pandemic related
reasons that could mean anything bro let
just think about this for a second
two
times more people decided that they
can't work because of pandemic related
reasons than the people who decided to
get a job in august yeah like we added
jobs but twice as many people said they
ain't going back
5.6 million americans
think of these numbers for a second
right i'm not a mathematician i just say
the numbers that they tell us and then
we just do some comparisons this is like
the walmart version of economics where
we just
get numbers we're bargain hunting yeah
and we just ask super simple questions
like you guys got the models you got the
charts the grass you got all the crazy
stuff we just asked simple questions
there's
10.5 million rolls open in america most
there's ever been world record
5.6 million people say they can't work
because of pandemic related reasons
what
what how do you decide that what does
that mean is it health related okay
there's probably legitimate reasons why
it's health related is it
psychologically related
maybe okay there's probably reasonable
uh things you could say there is it
economically related like can you
literally lose your job and be in such a
bad financial position that you then say
you can't get a job and work in the
workforce and that's a pandemic related
reason it sounds crazy but like i'm sure
there's somebody somewhere who has a
reasonable uh kind of rational thought
behind that
but the problem is that we don't know
and so when you have 10.5 million jobs
open and but 5.6 million people saying
that they can't work for pandemic
reasons
like again i'm not a genius i didn't go
to harvard but like
maybe we should take some of the people
and help fill some of the jobs and then
maybe what we should also do is start
asking questions as to how these numbers
are calculated
the fact that the economist and those
that were creating the expectations
about 725 000 people
725 000 payrolls we're gonna be added in
august and it came in at 235 000.
like if we don't fire anyone that's a
fireball offense right there do they at
least have a conversation like if i if
you and i were like going somewhere for
work and i was like joe
in 30 days there's going to be a number
reported your job is to figure out what
that number's going to i'm gonna give
you a team of a bunch of people to help
also yeah and i'm also going to give you
data yeah and i'm going to give you all
the information you need figure out what
the number's going to be and you said to
me
725 000 and it came in at 235 000.
if you were just an employee and we were
caught like colleagues i'd fire you if
you were my brother i'd smack you
like what is going on yeah i mean that's
a number you could have pulled out of a
hat and probably gotten closer too hey
give him credit it's trending in the
right direction
it's like hey you said it was gonna be
positive you want to bet you are
consistently inconsistent do you want to
make a bet
right now we've looked at zero data i'll
bet you right now there's a 50 50 shot
we're more accurate than they are for
the month of august or for the month of
september the one that's coming up i'll
call it right now four hundred fifty
thousand payrolls get added in september
doesn't even have to mark the data i
don't know you see the data there's a 50
50 shot i'm more accurate than that i
have pretty i'll uh i'm with you on 450.
i like that yeah best business show
research team 450 000 jobs in september
you heard it here first we made the
prediction on september 3rd economist
looking at no data no anything no you
guys go do all your calculations go be
wizards go use your calculators your
freaking pen protectors or pocket
protectors go whatever go do all your
nonsense we call it 425 000 right now in
september
450 now 450 whatever look it doesn't
even matter literally we don't even know
our own number we're still going to be
better off than you fools come on
like what is going on here i'm in on
that yeah 450. 450 000 jobs you heard it
here first in september right like come
on and by the way if we're right they
all better get fired if i if i find out
who creates these numbers and we
literally just picked the number out of
our ass and we are more accurate
we're mailing them this video for sure
oh we're down here in the video i'm
calling their boss i'm saying yo come on
hire me
i could do a couple of these it takes me
about five seconds each month to guess
the data i'll take half their pay [ __ ]
that sounds pretty good i mean what is
going on here like by the way i promise
you if we're more accurate than the
economist you better stay off the
internet when the job comes out next
month boys motors with the economic
predictions
listen you would have a better job
literally putting two treats out for a
dog and say it high or low and the dog
might have gotten it right the dog had a
better shot than the egg they were the
dogs that picked the super bowl winners
you just you pick the numbers like over
under 500. the dog's like what is going
on here this is atrocious and again like
we understand it's complex
but like you can't be this wrong there's
no way you can be this wrong and i don't
care what your reasoning behind it is
there's no way you can be this wrong and
still try to look me in the face and
tell me you know the numbers in
september hey guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
sofi.compomp and make sure you come back
and watch more of the best business show
we're gonna build the biggest business
show in the world and we need your help
[Music]